so let's talk about the assignment
we are going to play with paul hegbert's
business card ray tracer this is going
to be an enlightening experience
because it says it's a business card ray
tracer this sounds really good because
it can the whole code can fit on the
business card
of yours well you will see that this
does not mean that
this is well suited for educational
purposes so it's not very easy to
understand what is happening in there
in the package i have also included a
version that's a bit more
eye-friendly but when we are going to be
talking about global illumination
we're going to use a simple global
illumination program
and it's called small paint and i wrote
it myself
in a way that it would maximize
both understandability and conciseness
so here is the
first part which is not expected to be
so convenient
and then the next global illumination
program will be much more convenient
so to compile this you use whatever
tool you wish i'm not going to confine
you to use
any given tool this is a 1 or
maybe 2 3 5 ray tracer and
in the zip file that i will show you i
have
put a compiler for windows which is
called the mingw
this is a port of different unix
compilers to windows and they work quite
well
so you can use these if you're a windows
user and you don't like visual studio
you don't have visual studio or you
would like to try gcc under windows that
you can use this
if you would like to use something else
you're fine and if you're a linux guy
you're a power user
anyway so you can deal with that
yourself but if you need help just write
to me
okay so what is the practical part well
get this file
and there's going to be instructions in
the readme
and let's make images with different
maximum
depth values this means how many bounces
are we computing
and do this from one to five ounces and
see the difference in the output images
the question is what did you experience
visually and why there's going to be an
observations
text file and this is where you need to
write these down
but i'm going to discuss this on the
next slide and what i would like to
you to do is to crank up the depth value
to a really large number
and see what happens because maybe
interesting things will happen
and the question is what will be the
dependence of the run time
the execution time of the algorithm with
respect to this
depth variable and does it
abruptly change at a given point or
somewhere
or not
and usually there is a set of questions
for pros
so if you feel like a pro you should
definitely answer these
sometimes these are really difficult
questions sometimes not so much
and when i first had this course i
thought that
maybe 10 to 20 of the people that
would bother to try because they are
really interesting exercises
and to to my surprise
almost 70 or 80 percent of people of the
people in the first two years of this
course
did all the pro exercises
and some of them even came up with
exercises on their own because they
they thought that yeah this this is so
much fun i changed the code this way
look what i got what happened there and
and if you if you find out something
amazing then show it to me so i can also
marvel at that
so instead of questions for pros this is
plus points for the exam if you don't do
them
you still can get the maximum amount of
points for the assignment
but take a look and try to do them
because it's it's a really interesting
journey
the first is what would be the
algorithmic complexity of this depth
variable
so this means that i can not only
measure the execution time of the
algorithm
with respect to this depth but i can
also write
up the complexity of the algorithm with
the big old notation
the bigger notation this is something
that tells you the complexity of
algorithms with respect to variables
so if i change let's go back to
algorithms and data structures for
instance dijkstra's algorithm
if i remember correctly it's of
quadratic complexity so if i have
is it i think it is so it's it's really
favorable
so it means that if i have a bit
larger city where i need to find the
best route between two points
then the complexity of the algorithm is
not going to be
raised so much so this means that
if it's n squared it means that if i
have double the size
of the city then the algorithm is going
to run
four times as long so i would like to
know the complexity of this algorithm
that you have
with respect to this big o notation
second pro question is what could we do
to make this more favorable
whatever weird examples and ideas go
and if you did some change then tell me
the new complexity of the algorithm
and a regular set of questions play with
the aov variable it's very easy to find
out what it does already
question is what did you experience and
why and
just a note that there is a i think more
readable
version of the same c plus code
in the zip file the format
of the table that i would like to see is
that
we met we take the different numbers for
depth values maximum amount of bounces
and i would like to know the execution
time in seconds
and this is a text file
but after filling such a text file i
would like you to plot this with
whatever tool you have
i don't mind if you like new part use
that if you
like more from alpha or matlab use
whatever i don't mind
and please put a png file
of the plot also in your solutions
and one more set
of light paths this is waiting for you
so please draw a camera
on this image where it is exactly and
please
denote what kind of light paths do i
have here
and please tell me a few words about
whether i see these light paths or not
so for instance i definitely see a light
path that is
led because i can see the light source
so the ray that connects the eye to the
light source
is definitely accounted for because i
can see the light source
so what about the other light paths
and save it as a png or jpeg file
and this is just the names of the
different
files that i would like to see in your
submission
and this is how the submission itself
should be named
and about the deadline i don't know yet
apparently
easter is coming and when i first had
this course
i told the other people that well next
week there's going to be
another lecture and they said well not
really because there is easter break
and i come from hungary where easter
break is born one day
so it means that on monday you get drunk
and on tuesday you go back to work with
a hangover
and then they told me that it's well
it's not only monday
so next wednesday is going to be skipped
because it's easter break and i said
well maybe they are trolling me but
maybe it's true i don't know
okay then the one stay after that and
they said
uh-uh not even that and i was like i'm
surely
i'm surely being trolled by like 20
people at the same time
and then they told me that easter break
in austria
is two weeks at least in the
universities and i was like that's
amazing because in hungary
on that monday that you have as easter
egg everyone is drunk this
is ridiculous like the whole city goes
crazy
and in austria i imagine that their
saying may happen but for two weeks so
it's an amazing country thanks for your
attention and see you
sometime i will announce when the next
lecture happens
thank you